[Music]
Aloha is directed by Cameron Crowe and
stars Bradley Cooper Emma Stone Rachel
McAdams and John Krasinski as well as
Bill Murray I mean that's a pretty
awesome cast and a pretty good director
and writer so I'm expecting a pretty
awesome or at least pretty good movie
right I'm a big fan of Simha Crowes work
I like say anything quite a bit I also
like Jerry Maguire quite a bit I'm
really excited to see what he does
whenever he makes a movie because even
in his failures there's always at least
some really interesting dialog from time
to time this movie takes place in Hawaii
with Bradley Cooper as this guy in a
military who's there to perform this
blessing that's occurring he knows
someone who's well respected in the
Hawaiian community and emma stone plays
this young like fiery and ready to go
person she's there with him and they're
trying to figure out how this is all
going to go down Rachel McAdams plays a
former flame who now has kids and a
husband and there's sort of a love
triangle there which is always wonderful
in movies Aloha was a big disappointment
for me because I go into a Cameron Crowe
movie expecting certain things and I go
into movies expecting one specific thing
and that is called coherence I like what
movies make sense I like when things
happen in the order in which they should
happen now that being said it's really
cool to see a unique and different movie
that's actually original and there are
aspects of Aloha that are like that
there are times throughout this movie
where I was like this is a really
different and unique movie I like this
scene this is a well-written scene this
is good performances well this is really
cool and then the next scene it's like
this random thing that makes no sense
why is it there and actors who are doing
things in a scene that just don't make
sense it's movie dialogue and what I
mean by that is sometimes you go to a
movie and you hear people talking
specifically children in movies talking
and you're like they would never say
that a kid would never say that people
would never say that this is movie
dialogue that's what a large majority of
Aloha feels like people saying really
clever things written by a really clever
person but pushing those things aside
what is one of the most important things
that a romantic film should have
chemistry between the people who are
supposed to be romantically involved in
some way and it's non-existent between
Emma Stone and Bradley Cooper they might
respect each other professionally as
actors
but you never feel that flame on-screen
because a large majority of the movie is
Bradley Cooper hating Emma Stone even
being there so it's kind of hard to
create that feeling and sometimes in a
movie you can for instance as good as it
gets with Jack Nicholson and Helen Hunt
these two characters don't really get
along for a large portion of the movie
but you're supposed to care about their
relationship and it works so well
because of the dialogue and those actors
being so good here that similar type of
trope between characters where one hates
the other person but the other one's
kind of like into him it just doesn't
work because that chemistry that flame
that intensity that passion you can't
feel it the other thing that was a
little strange about this movies it
since it takes place in Hawaii
Cameron Crowe decided to have all of
these spiritualistic Hawaiian undertones
in the movie like rituals and various
things that are part of the Hawaiian
culture these are all really beautiful
things as depicted in the movie and I'm
not like trashing on that I'm just
saying that it really felt odd and out
of place and I think that's this movie's
biggest flaw there are so many random
things thrown throughout this story that
make it so inept and completely
incoherent and you just can't really
feel it or follow it because they're
characters who are strolling through
various scene setups that's what it
feels like here we have this scene do
something witty and clever now we have
this scene let's talk about the Hawaiian
culture now we have this scene let's
talk about a satellite that was launched
into space it just doesn't mesh the
whole movie feels like this giant mess
of various ideas that could have been
good if they were in a coherent picture
now that being said despite the fact
that these actors don't really work that
well together they're not giving bad
performances I think everyone's on their
a game they're just stuck in a movie
that is not on the same game that
they're on and at one point in the movie
I was like is this going to be another
one of those two and a half hour
comedies because it just felt like it
was going on and on this movie isn't
even two hours long that's not good the
pacing is not good either
Aloha was a big disappointment I liked
certain scenes in this movie there were
certain moments of charm some of the
characters were nice and fun characters
but they just didn't fit in and Bill
Murray was a complete waste in this
movie he had nothing cool to do he was
just oh I'm gonna give Aloha a c-minus
it's a movie that has some clever scenes
but those clever scenes feel like just
that clever scenes like a good scene you
might watch on YouTube that's a three
minute clip and then you don't watch the
rest of the movie and you think what
movies probably pretty good and you
watch them all strung together and
you're like what did I just see guys I'm
curious to know what you thought of
Aloha if you did see it and thank you so
much as always for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck Minh iced
[Music]